[音楽]
ムートン
みなさんこんにちは
エイチラボ仕様の高田シューターです
突然ですが
皆さんに質問です
皆さんにとって普通って
何ですか
って言葉を聞いた時にどういうイメージを持たれますか
ちょっと考えてみてください
どうでしょうか
大多数の人の意見だとか大多数の人が持っている常識ってものを
普通
って考えた人もいらっしゃるかもしれません
では
別の質問にしてみましょう
あなたは
普通ですか
ちょっと困っちゃったかもしれないですね
でも大丈夫です
今の困るのが普通なんで
さっきからコイツは一体何の質問してんだとそう思った方もいらっしゃるかもしれませ
ん
ですがこの普通という言葉が今日僕が皆さんにお話したい
トークのテーマになります
ちょっとだけ自分の話をさせてください
高校生の時僕はは勉強もまあ真面目にあって運動会とか文化祭とかそういった学校教授
にむちゃくちゃ力をれていた
まあ普通の個性でしたその僕に親が一言をこういったんですね
入学してみたらシューター
そこでまぁ多分本当0.1秒ぐらいで僕行ったんですよ
な事するわけねーじゃん
高校者的なんで
きたな言葉遣いを許してください
でも本当はその時僕はやっぱり怖かったんですよね
英語はやっぱ全然しゃべれない僕は中学3年生の時にアメリカに初めて知って生かして
もらってでもその時に大ターっていう誰もが通じなくて
水が by 県で買えなくて喉渇いて死にそうになったそれがもうトラウマになってて
ましてや自分の高校で1年留学する人なんて誰もいませんでした
行かない理由なんてほんといっぱいありますよむちゃくちゃ頑張った学校行事を
留学したら一回2切符じゃなきゃいけないし
大学受験どうすんなのか
だから留学するってことは普通のことじゃなかったんです
だから僕は高校生の時に留学はしませんでした
大学に入って1年生の時は手品のサークルに入って
手品の練習に明け暮れていました
的なに勉強もしていわゆるこれの時も普通の大学生でした
その時たまたま高校時代からお世話になった先輩とばったり出会って立ち話してたら
こんなこと言われたんです
日米学生会議って知ってる
参加してみたら
この日米学生会議っていうのは日米の大学生が70名ほどですね
1カ月間食べをしながら社会問題について英語で議論する学生団体です
出ました英語です英語僕にとってのトラウマ
さっきも言ったように
水が通じなくて買えなくて留学も言い訳していかなくて
だから日米学生会議って言ったものに参加するのは僕にとっては普通のことじゃなかっ
たんですよ
だから行くわけないじゃんって思った時に先輩行ったんですよね
僕もこの夏参加してさすっごい楽しかったんだよね
えっ先輩も参加したんだ
いや確かに優秀の先輩なんですよでも帰国州でもなくて
まあ普通の先輩というかいや優秀なんですよなんですけど普通の先輩なんですだから
あの先輩でもできたんだから売れも参加したら楽しめるんじゃねぇ均じゃねって思った
んですよ
もう一度言いますけどねっ
事務所の先輩れ尊敬してます
日米学生会議に参加するということは普通じゃない英語ペラペラな人だか議論得意な人
とか
自分とは違う特別の人が参加するもんだと思っていました
でも気付いたらその年僕はに白い学生会議に参加していてその翌年
なぜかアメリカに留学してたんです
英語を使ったり
留学するってことが僕にとって普通のことにいつのまにかなっていたんです
もう一つエピソードをシェアさせてください
その西部学生限り出会った友達がある日日本の教育の課題を解決したいからハーバード
とか
まあとにかく世界中大学生を日本に連れてきて日本の高校生に1週間くらいのサマー
スクールをやりたい
って相談してきたんです
最初聞いたときはいやいや無理しちゃう普通に考えてそんなんできるわけないじゃん
んだけ
お金が必要でどんだけ人を手伝ってもらえなきゃいけないな
とにかくそんなことを思いました
またできない理由探しているんですね
ただその愛では本当に素晴らしくてその彼は当然できる仕上げる視聴みたいなそんな
スタンスで話してくるんですよ
なんかそうすると仲間で話してるとなんか俺は的んじゃでこれって何度思って
そんな気がしてきたんです
これが実は今僕が仕事にしているエイチラボ
この活動の始まりでその相談してきた友人が一緒にイチローを始めた
小林です
最初は大学生同士のなんの木ない普通の会話から始まったんです
確かにアイデアは斬新で当時普通なものではありませんでしたけどみんなで話している
うちに何かその間が普通なことに思えてきて
気づいたらお金がないって思ったらじゃあ企業に頭下げてお金を出していただいたりと
か
場所がないってなったら隣の旅館まあとりあえず
貸切にしてくださいお願いしますと言って頭を下げてこれないんですけどその時
当時は自分たちは絶対できるって思い込んでなのでそれをやる
実施するってことが普通のことで当たり前のことだったんです
おかげでそのサマースクールが今10年続いてるんですよ
はじめに僕は皆さんにあなたは普通ですかと問いかけさせてもらいました
実はこの質問は僕をずーっと苦しめてきたものなんです
僕は普通であることが本当にコンプレックスだったと
なんでかというとここまでは例えば偏差値のようなわかりやすい指標
目標にして勉強してば良かったしそれが楽しい事って言われて
まあ決まった答えがあるテストを受けてマールをたくさんもらってそれでいい点数を
取るとか
それができることが素晴らしいそれを目指すのが普通だ
その価値観を暗黙のうちに植え付けられて
付
それが当たり前で疑問を持つことすらなかったんです
けど高校を出るとこれまでと違うメッセージが社会に溢れてるんですよね
やれ個性を伸ばせ大投手つした人材になるとかいや何それって感じですよね
この人と同じ尺度で頑張ってきて同じようなことしてきて
それで評価されてる自分って普通なの
じゃあ2てもその普通がダメなのみたいな
そこで急に普通の自分というものにコンプレックスを抱き始めるんです
皆さんの中にももしかしたら同じような経験がある人
いらっしゃるんじゃないでしょうか
高校を出た瞬間意欲的になれだ主体的になれだとかそういう人間でありなさいって言わ
れて
q 2今までと逆のこと言われてる感じになるんですよね
もしかして就活している大学生の方いらっしゃればこういうこと言われるかもしれませ
ん
画一的で普通の人材を求めてません
思うんですけど誰しも自分の中に光るものと輝くもの
そういうものがありたいって思っているはずなんですよ
自分には才能があって何か将来やり遂げられるはずだとか達成できるはずだっていうの
が根底にある思いだと思うんです
つまり他の人に埋もれる普通の人じゃない何者かになりたい
そういったのが根源的な欲求なのかもしれません
そういう人って結構多いんじゃないですかね多分今日このトーク聞いてくれている
あなたはこっちがの人間だと思っています勝手にどうでしょう
家2してません
で皆さんが気になるのはどうやったら普通じゃなくなることができるのか
それが今日の僕のトークのテーマです
気になりますよね
その答えは
そんなことはできない
あなたはずーっと普通なんです
ただ
その普通はアップデートしていくことができるのです
どういうことって今ちょっと思った方はいらっしゃるかもしれないですね
先ほど僕が皆さんにお話したエピソードがヒットした
貧富になります
一つ目は
先輩の影響で日米学生会議参加して留学したり
まあそういったことするようになった話
二つ目は世界中の大学生を集めて方向性だけのサマースクールエイチラボ
一から作り上げた話です
この2つのエピソードにおいて僕はずーっと普通です
ゲイ何言ってんだって感じかもしれませんがこれから話すこと言ったらちょっとわかる
と思います
でもその普通中でも明確に変化が起きているんですよね
それ何かっていう話です
一つ目は英語を使ったりメーカーに行ったりすること自体もともと自分には抵抗感が
あってトラウマだったわけで
それはそういったことをするのは普通じゃないって思って自分が
今では当たり前のように英語も使ってアメリカも行くようになってい
つまりそれが普通のことになりました
二つ目は
前例がなくできっこないと思ったサマースクールがもう何か傷から10年続いてるわけ
ですね
今では毎年開催していてこれがもう僕にとっての普通になってるんですよ
つまり自分の中における普通っていうのがアップデートされた
そんなことになるんです
どうやってこの普通がプレッツェルとかちょっと思い出してみてください
それは前
人と話したっていうところなんですよね
例えば日米学生会議の例は先輩と話して生意気にも
4の先輩できるんだから俺もやるんじゃねーかっ
を持って踏み出してみたわけです
サマースクールは友達た多く歳話しているうちになんか自分にもできるんじゃないかな
持って必死でやってみたん
いずれも最初は自分にとってできない普通じゃないと思ったことが身近な
た車
に耳カットとかポイントなんですが身近な場所の影響でこれで金じゃねって思ったし
行動に移すことができたんです
身近にいる自分と違う他者との対応を通じて自分の中の普通っていうものがプレイドさ
れたということになります
僕はこれをピアメンタリングと呼んでいます
ピアっていうのは仲間とか同僚とかそういった意味で
身近な他者を示します
お互いに助言したり応援しちゃったりする関係まつまりメンターでありんめん t で
ありそういった関係性でお互いの気づきを促して普通っていうのはプレーとしていくん
です
ちょっと想像してみてください
例えばじゃあ日本の総理大臣が
いや僕留学して人生変わったよ皆さんもぜひ留学してくださいって言ったとしましょう
それってでも心のどこかではいやいや症になるようなあなただからできたんでしょうと
か
あなただから成功したんでしょうまあそう思っちゃいますよね
けどそれがもし身近な友達とか会社の同僚とか下がったらどうでしょうか
まず多分その人の話に耳を傾けるし
できたんだったら俺にもできんじゃねぇ
じゃいませんか
偉人や成功者の話っていうのも落ち着く分ナビがあるし
すごいたちのことです
ですが自分の中の普通っていうものをアップデートして自ら行動に移していくにはパリ
一番影響力があるのは身近にある
たような他者のです
そこから学ぶことが大事なんです
そしてここからはもう一個大事なことを
この中でこのプロセスを通じてアプレットされた普通っていうのは最初はあなたの友人
が持っていた普通でそれがいつもにかあなたの普通になっています
多分またこの誰か普通なっていくんですよね
こうやって普通ってのはどんどんアップデートされながら伝播していくんです
それが社会全体の普通になっていくです
思い返してみればさっきの留学の話僕の高校では当時留学をする人はほぼいませんでし
た
なんですけどこの前北尾根回ちょっと聞いてみたら最近かなり多くの人が留学する
らしいですよ
僕はその当時の僕はね留学するなんて普通じゃないってきたのは逆にとおかしいくらい
でこの10年ちょっとの間に留学生人は上座に増えていって
今では母校の生徒たちにとっては留学するというのは当たり前
学校全体の普通っていうのがプレイされたことになるのです
[音楽]
つまり時にこの個人の普通っていうもののアップデートが社会の普通ってものを
アップデートして
もしかしたらイノベーションを起こすきっかけになるかもしれない僕はそう思ってい
ます
ただその第一歩っていうのはやっぱり3時から
たような他者との対話でしょ
なんか対話している時に捕逸の間普通じゃねーなーとか
これ普通じゃねーぞって思ったらあなたの普通をアップするチャンスです拒否するん
じゃないこれこそが学びの近いなんです
そういった他者との対応2して学び合うことすごい大事でこのピアメンタリングって
いうのを生み出していくためにイマココ
実際僕が取っている収録している下北沢103円くらい入る量をとつくりましたここで
毎日
共に暮らし共に学ぶそういった空間を作っています
大学生とか社会人っていうのが共に住んで対応通ずる
自分の中の普通はプレーとしていて最終的に自ら行動に移していく
その支援を今僕は仕事としてやっています
さてへ
僕はテックスのほかの登壇者の方が違ってぶっちゃけ何かすでにすごいことを成し遂げ
きたりとかなカット大成功したとか
まあそういったわけでもないし有名だったわけでもありません
さっきも言ったように2
数であることがコンプレックスだったまぁそんなやつです
はそんな僕にも一つここの人に負けない自信があるところがあります
それが自分にはないことができる人とか自分にはない強みを持った人に出会った時に
押しおこう
まあそういったところですねここだけは自信あるんです
たとえばさっきの留学日米学生会議の先輩
あの先輩にできたんだから俺もできんじゃねって思った瞬間
でもかんでも聞きましたね留学な人か汚れましょうか
こうやってやっぱりいつでも学びのアンテナを立てておくこと
そうするとやっぱり身近な他者から学ぶ事が出来て最終的には自分の中の普通 or
プレートしていくことができるんじゃないかな
そう思っています
あともう一個オススメなまあ自分に対して投げかける質問があります
それはあの人だったらどう考えるかというものです
やっぱり留学日米学生会議に関してもあの先輩だったらどうなのか
あの先輩にとっては留学日米学生権に参加することは普通だったわけですよね
やっぱりその人の中にどういう風にとらえているかというのを考えてみると羽生その人
にとっては普通だってことに気づけるはずです
やだからいろいろしゃべったんですけどマジで
fedex なんて聞かなくていいですよ
すごい実績を残した人の話とか僕みたいなちょっと距離がある
1話距離も
いつもあっている友達とか
まあクラスメイトとか会社の同僚と
まあ今日見たテレビの話とかじゃなくて将来の話とか
お互いの普通を確かめ合う
そんな会話は対話をぜひ知ってほしいですね
それが本当に大事なんです
だからちょっとこれは動画早くね切手ですね友達とズーの見直してください
それが皆さんの学びになるんです
ズームのメットはコロナのジョシュ君ができますからこれこれが言い訳できないですよ
なのでさっさとこの動画を切って
飲みください
ぜひピアとの対話を全力で楽しんで皆さんの中の普通をアップデートして報道に移して
生きてください
ご静聴ありがとうございましたまたお会いしましょうバイバイ
[音楽]